Dr. Chaos, do you dare open the doors to doom?
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. And I'm Sean.
And again, that is it.
We have been abandoned.
And we're abandoned in a haunted castle this time.
Is it a castle?
Looks like a house. Can it really be described as a castle?
Yeah, exactly. I mean, I guess a house is a man's castle.
We have a lot of house cleaning here to do right at the top, Sean.
How so? Well, did you just say house so?
Was you making a very clever house pun?
I didn't mean to.
That's very funny.
Well, you know, first off, what a title.
Dr. Chaos.
Yeah. What are you what are you expecting?
Well, we were just having a conversation.
We were having a conversation. Me, you and one other person that shall not be named at this moment.
And he can he said that it was like a prog metal album, which I thought was I thought was actually pretty apt.
What I what I was expecting was probably just another bland 3D.
I'm sorry. Another bland side scrolling platformer of, you know, maybe it's going to have some spooky like vampires or something.
I don't know. And you weren't expecting this game to be like an autobiography of Joseph Kanopka.
Could you could you elaborate on that?
Joseph Kanopka, also known as Dr.
Chaos, was an American citizen who served 16 years of a 20 year prison sentence for two felony acts of conspiracy to commit acts of terror.
So, OK, this is part of, you know, of this is a blind spot of mine, I guess.
What were these acts of terror he was going to commit?
Well, they were only conspiracy.
So we you know, we can't I don't want to pin the guy down and say that he was definitely going to do these things because technically he didn't get a chance to go through with them.
But he is Dr.
Chaos. That's how he was referred to.
And if you try to look up Dr.
Chaos, you won't get the NES game.
I guarantee it. I guarantee even if you like only search for NES games, you're going to get this guy first.
Oh, my God. All right.
Yeah. I'm looking at the Wikipedia page now.
Yeah, he definitely looks like he might.
I think it's the sunglasses.
Yeah. He looks more like an agent of chaos than a Dr.
Chaos. I wonder what his I wonder what his big plan was.
Well, enough about him.
And let's talk about Dr.
Jin Chaos, who is the mad physicist that the game is named after.
What were your I don't even want to ask, like, what were your impressions of this guy?
I don't think we ever really see him.
But I don't Dr.
Jin Chaos is a pretty cool name.
And I will say that looking through the manual, this is one of the more coherent and cogent backstories.
So much so that it actually like it.
It does make sense when you're playing the game that this is sort of what's happening.
It's not a good story.
And it has plot holes even in like the summary.
I don't know why in the letter that he leaves, he says that you, your brother of of just a generic background of the only one that can save the house and the world.
But, you know, we're getting there.
It's not a bunch of word salads now.
Yeah, it's kind of fun until they just named the other character Michael.
Like, you mean, Dr.
Jin Chaos's brother is just Michael Chaos?
Wow. I mean, is this just because like, do you feel like you have like a complex about your name, Mike?
Well, first off, I will say that they were probably making some reference to the archangel Michael, who, you know, defeated Satan.
Who's actually named after you.
Right. Everybody knows that part, too.
Yeah. You know, just the interesting thing here, I guess, is that why go through all the trouble?
Like Dr. Jin Chaos feels like that was left over from the Japanese side of the game.
And then they forgot to translate that.
And instead they just translated the brother's name to Michael because that's very English facing.
I mean, I guess what I would say and Jin sounds like a pretty English name and chaos is an English word.
But I guess what you could do to, you know, headcanon this is to just say that it's like a very like, I don't know, like a Slavic name, like Chopped Chouse or something like that.
I guess I'm just a little.
Yeah, sure.
That sounds great, too.
Chouse. I like that.
Or, you know, the Sonic Adventure Chouse, the Chow Garden.
Yeah. Are you familiar with that?
Yeah. I had Chouse.
Because they're technically chaos because of the chaos emeralds in Sonic, but we call them Chouse instead.
Yeah. I think that I actually never heard the word Chow in like an official capacity.
It was just. I'm making it official right now, right here.
I'm taking my stand.
Come after me, Sonic fans.
Yeah. There are dozens of you.
I will stand beside you.
And we have, you know, Dr.
Jin Chaos, who's invented an interdimensional warp gate, which grants access to other worlds.
But unfortunately, that portal invites a world of monsters into the castle.
Michael. His younger brother, just a regular guy named Michael, shows up just in time to notice that his brother, Dr.
Chaos, is missing.
And then he goes and tries to fix everything.
And that's what you do in the game.
Because you are Michael.
You are Michael.
You don't think they picked Michael because of like Michael Jackson or Michael Jordan?
Like. I think he's supposed to be an everyman and nobody of note has ever really been named Michael.
Understood. Okay.
Yep. I think there's like a council of Michaels who would like to differ with you there.
So, Dr.
Chaos, you start, you're Michael, you start right outside the house.
I think it's cute that they let you start outside the house because you can't walk around outside.
It's just jump up the first step, which is something everybody does, right?
You can't just walk up your steps.
You got to jump up over that.
Yeah. It's for the immersion. Yeah, I get it.
And you might hit your head on the doorframe after the jump.
So, they very literally coded that in there, too.
Great. And then you walk in through the door and, you know, I hear monsters came through an interdimensional
portal and I think like, all right, that sounds like we're going to see some pretty scary stuff.
And then it's just like mice and bats.
Okay. Well, that's just like what happened to the house while it's been without a caretaker.
You know, like the door was wide open.
When you go on vacation, your house just has mice and bats when you come back?
If I left the door open like his brother was, yeah.
All right. No, I can deal with that.
I mean, in Animal Crossing, if you don't visit your house for a while, there's like cockroaches
inside. Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, this is just the things that happen.
With thisanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanhaanha
Let's just rewind for a second
because we didn't talk about the title screen,
which is pretty epic.
It's a blood-dripping title screen
with Dr. Chaos, like, written in blood.
Oh, yeah. A skull pops up through the O.
Yeah, I did appreciate that if you stuck around,
there was a lot of cool stuff to see.
Like, you see some weird dude in the window.
It looks like he goes and stabs somebody.
I was very impressed by the blood-dripping
and just how metal it looked.
But it doesn't seem to be all that tied to the game itself.
Well, that's what I was going to mention,
is not only does it not feel tied to the game,
because this feels almost like a Resident Evil-style opening,
you know, and then you don't quite have that gameplay experience.
But, you know, this also doesn't feel on brand for Nintendo.
Like, blood, is that even allowed?
I guess you could say it's ketchup,
but it just feels like they would not want that as the title screen.
Yeah, I mean, they have...
I know that, like, later in...
Later they were more okay with it,
but I did not see this coming on the NES.
I mean, we have seen some intense stuff already,
but this is probably as overt as it's gotten.
Yeah, and then there's this strike of lightning on the screen,
and then Dr. Chaos just disappears, that text,
and you just see the house itself.
And I was like, what does that mean?
What is that foreshadowing?
I don't think...
You're getting a lot of symbolism in this game
that I don't think is actually there, Mike.
We haven't even started pushing buttons.
We haven't. We're just talking about the story and the title screen.
You know it's good. Yeah.
But when you do start playing,
you've got to explore the house,
which is a pretty big house,
but you're only, like, allowed to go through, like,
certain points when you first start.
So you just have a few doors to explore,
and you have a knife,
which feels like a good thing to bring with you
when you go to see your brother.
Yeah, I usually do.
Yeah, and you have this knife,
and you take on the bats and the mice,
why do they respawn immediately?
Okay, so this is going to sort of conflict
with what I just said about how these mice and bats
are just completely a normal thing
if you leave your door open,
because it seems that they get sucked back
into, like, this warp portal thing,
because they turn into, like, bubbles,
and they just move around,
and they respawn, like, where the bubbles last are.
Like, did you notice that?
I didn't really, I don't understand it,
but I guess that's the way that they,
they deal with enemy respawns.
That's their point in the interdimensional warp gate.
They're, like, assigned those coordinates.
Yeah. Oh, okay.
I mean, no, that's me just, again,
bringing a much deeper story to this.
But didn't you find that frustrating,
that, like, imagine if you stomped on a Goomba
in Super Mario Bros.,
and then it just respawned
where you first saw it on screen, immediately.
I would think that there was something broken.
But I don't think that,
I think this is what they intended.
I don't know why they intended it.
But, yeah. And that's something that just happens
throughout the entirety of the game, too.
It's not just in this opening hallway.
It's not, like, a bug or anything.
So I agree with you that they probably meant it.
I'm just not sure if it's a great design decision
off the bat.
You know, it's very unwelcoming
because if you're just kind of testing things out,
you might not have figured out yet,
like, how to efficiently use your knife
or, like, how to explore things.
So you're just kind of walking around this house,
getting hit left and right by bats and mice.
And I know that doesn't sound like it could happen.
But, you know, if you are just kind of feeling out the game,
I can see that happening to a kid.
Well, I can give you a story of how I felt at the game
on my first playthrough.
Please! So, to preface,
the walking around the hallways
is just one part of this game.
The second part is a very Goonies-esque,
almost pretty much the exact same style of gameplay
of walking into a room,
and now it's first person,
and you can click on things and interact with them,
which I'm sure we'll get into in more detail in a moment.
But, you know, I go into this room,
and I start clicking on things,
and I immediately see a door open,
and this goofball come out,
and chase me out into the hallway,
and then he bashes my head in,
and that was in 50 seconds.
Like, the game lasted 50 seconds
until that happened.
So I'm like, I don't know if this game is just, like,
not gonna fuck around with you,
or if that was a random event.
I couldn't tell.
I mean, it didn't happen the next time I played,
but... So that's the craziest thing, Sean,
and we will talk about the first person
in more detail later,
but since you brought it up,
in the first person mode,
you have to open up doors,
and open up windows,
and open up closets and drawers,
and what have you, and if you leave those things open,
and go to another screen,
and then come back to the screen
where you left things open,
there is a random chance
that a giant enemy of sorts,
like a Frankenstein or a mummy,
one of those characters
will just appear in that
because you left it open.
What a scary thing.
That's actually more impressive than I thought.
Because that is something
that you think about.
I want to keep my eye on this open closet
when I'm a child,
and I'm afraid of the closet,
because if I look away,
something might happen. So I like that.
I like that. But the uncertainty of it all, too.
Like, never, as a child,
when you go to check your closet,
do you assume that there will be
a 100% chance of nothing,
but then going forward,
a 50% chance every time you check it
if you leave it open.
Yeah, right.
I'm not thinking about it probabilistically,
I guess.
It's just insane,
because you never get surprised
by a Frankenstein or the like
when you open up the doors
on the first time.
But there is something really,
you know, like,
this is the first time I've felt horror
in an NES game.
Wow. You know, Castlevania,
a game that is definitely
within that genre,
is not scary at all
compared to the idea
of an enemy
that is going to destroy you
until you eventually, like,
collect the proper equipment
and, you know,
have, like, your gun loaded
and stuff. If you just, like,
stumble across one of those guys
early on, there's really no chance
of surviving. Yeah.
No, I died immediately,
like I said. And it also didn't help
that for these kinds of enemies,
like these stalker-type enemies,
they actually,
for the NES,
they have some, they have a pretty, like,
creepy design. Oh, yeah, absolutely.
They're up there with the designs of, like,
you know, the later bosses
in Castlevania,
like Grim Reaper and,
or they, I think they call it death
in Castlevania.
But, you know, that style of thing
I thought was really crazy
to see so early on
in the game. But it does make you,
I think it's something that needs to happen
to every player
to make you a little more cautious
of how you explore the castle.
Yeah, I think you're right.
Or regular home,
depending on how you look at
this game. All right,
so let's just stay
in the hallways for a second
because that's our,
like, 2D platformer
way of playing the game.
Not a lot goes on there.
That is strictly just for,
like, traversing the overworld,
if you will, right? Yeah,
it's, depending on where you are,
it's, like, a little bit of platforming,
a little bit of avoiding,
like, shit mobs.
And if you do run into
these monsters
in the rooms,
that's where the battle
would take place.
Right. And so what was your, like,
exploration process,
like, in the house?
Did you just go
from right to left
as you went to, like,
each door? Yeah,
I tried. There were some doors
that kind of move you
into different parts
of the house, so it's a little disorienting
when that happens. But,
yeah, I tried to just do
a clean sweep.
And, yeah,
that's it. Yeah,
because I think the manual lays it out
that you need to
find these warp zones
that Dr.
Chaos has opened up,
and it kind of
explains that to you,
but it doesn't really
tell you where
these warp zones are
or how exactly
to find them. And so,
when you start off
this game, you are kind of
left to just
going into the
first doors or any of the doors
you see and just kind of
poking around and hoping you
find something, right?
Yeah, I think that's
what you're meant
to do. I still couldn't
really understand
what a warp zone
was,
because apparently
they are just
doors and windows,
but I thought,
because at the end of the manual,
it gives you some tips,
and then they're like,
look for this thing
first. And I'm like,
okay, I would look for this
thing in the same way
that I would look for anything
by just, you know,
randomly checking doors.
So I wasn't sure
what that was supposed to accomplish.
Yeah, and I think you're talking about the
ultra space sensor.
Yeah, exactly.
So I don't know where that is,
but... And just to show you
how crazy it is
that, like, you know,
you didn't necessarily know where that was,
I didn't know where that was,
in Nintendo Power
issue number seven,
which is like, we're only on number three
right now, chronologically,
with Dr. Chaos.
So it shows you how much later
they finally get around
to answering this. in the Counselor's Corner
section of issue seven
of Nintendo Power, somebody just finally
asked, like, where is the
ultra space sensor?
Like, they had to address it.
The very first item
in a video game,
and they have to, like,
use a section of their guide
to tell people,
like, you know, this is the same thing
with, like, how do I get
infinite lives
in Super Mario Brothers?
and then it's like, in Dr.
Chaos, how do I start the game?
Yeah, exactly. I had to,
like, I had to go into,
I had to watch a video
just to get to the first,
like, warp area.
So, I guess,
that sort of tells you,
I know we're getting ahead
of ourselves a little bit, but that sort of tells you
how obtuse this game can be.
That, yeah, you had,
they had to answer it
in a magazine, and I couldn't play it
for, like, the first hour.
Yeah, I think that's crazy,
and, uh,
the game, the game does pick up
a little bit, though, if you manage to find
the ultra space sensor,
and you have, like,
an idea of,
because that is the gameplay loop,
essentially. You traverse the hallways,
find the correct door,
navigate through the,
uh, first person mode
in the room, find the warp zone,
go into the,
uh, warp world,
if you will, and then,
uh, collect the item
after defeating the boss
of that warp world,
and then coming back out
and doing the whole thing
over again. So I think it's very important
that,
um, they should have laid that out
a lot cleaner,
even in the manual, just explaining how to do
the first one, because aren't there,
like, 11 or 12?
Yes. There are 11 pieces
that you have to gather,
and apparently you need
one to find the rest,
and it's all just,
it's all the same to them.
So is it, there's really no harm
in including the first one,
though, right? In the manual?
I, I wouldn't say so.
Yeah, I think that, like,
I've seen, we've seen several manuals
now that have, like,
a, a beginner's hand-holding
strategy guide
for the first thing,
and I'm not saying that
a game should need
something like that,
um, but I,
I, I thought that this kind of game
could have helped with one.
Yeah, yeah.
And, and so let's talk about
that first person
exploring the rooms,
because you mentioned
Goonies 2, and I think that's very apt,
but we, um,
you know, we've learned a little bit
since then, but I imagine a lot of people
who didn't pick up Goonies 2
and found this game, they,
they'd have that same
learning curve, at the start,
you know, of what is a first person
like thing, I've never played
computer games before,
uh, now I own this game
on the NES, what do,
how did you, uh,
did you like how they
handled it, with the commands
on screen, and the,
uh, exploration with the
compass and stuff,
explain yourself.
Explain myself.
Uh, I thought that
it worked, like,
given, given what it is,
it worked, uh, it took me a moment
to, uh,
get the hang of the
controls in that situation,
where you sort of have to
hold down a button in order
to pick your command,
um, and when you're not holding
down that button, it's just a,
sort of a free look thing,
um, but I eventually got the
hang of it, uh,
I, I guess, like,
in this,
in this mode,
it's where a lot of that
obtuseness comes from as
well, because you have a hit
button, and that is your
designated break down
the wall, and I'm,
I just haven't been a
fan of that mechanic,
and to make it,
like, one of the, like,
the things that are just, it's one of your verbs,
is to hit a wall,
like, hit down the wall.
I, I found, I found that to be kind
of annoying. I,
I don't know how, what your thoughts were.
Well, you know, Sean,
I, I definitely agree that
hit one is a mistake,
but I'd argue that the
whole context thing,
while, while handled appropriately,
is, is a mistake,
you know? You don't need to switch
between open,
get, go,
and hit. That should all be
contextual for the game to
know, based on where your cursor
is. Like,
if you put the cursor
in front of a door,
and press the,
the A button, it should know that that,
that you want to open it.
You're right. And if you put it over a gun,
it should know that you want to
get it. Like,
you shouldn't have to, I'm sure that it's like,
a way that they program the game
that it needed, that,
uh, differentiator,
but, uh,
like a better programmed game
would just know,
based on context,
what to do. see, I guess what I,
so what I'm coming from,
when I look at this menu,
it reminds me very much,
like, uh, the,
um, adventure games that
they had moved on from,
you have to type out
every action you wanted to do,
like, go east, go west,
whatever, and they just made it,
like, uh, a menu of
selectable actions,
and, when I,
when I looked at it that way,
it made sense, but now,
like, now that you're saying this,
I'm, I'm realizing,
like, oh, there's only,
there aren't any context things
that you can do with each item,
like, you're only going to be able
to pick up a gun,
you're only going to be able
to open up a closet door,
it's not like you can do anything else
with these items, so,
if it, if that was the case,
then this menu would have reason
to exist, but,
it doesn't,
so, it doesn't need to exist.
Right, like, say you needed to inspect the gun,
or swap the gun,
you know, like, that would make sense
for a different context,
but they didn't, they didn't do that here,
and to address your,
your hit complaint,
the biggest complaint I have
with hit in this game,
which I think is very similar
to what the Goonies 2 problem was,
is that hit becomes
a very vague thing
that only works on,
um, objects or places
that are not marked for it,
so, there's never, like,
a, oh,
there's a dent in the wall,
I should hit that,
like, it's always just,
hit everything,
and hope something happens,
and that's not fun.
No, and I,
and I know that we're not
at the level of,
uh, visual accuracy
that you can make
a very subtle,
like, a subtly broken wall,
like, it's going to be obvious,
so that kind of, that would defeat their purpose
of making it hidden,
but all you've done
by going the other way
is making this
much more frustrating
for me. Yeah,
and in this one, different than the Goonies 2,
there's also no one
to talk to in these rooms
to, like, gain clues
or, um,
get context to where things might be
or warp zones
might be placed.
There's nothing like that,
so you just, you just have empty rooms
to explore and open things up.
Yeah, I think,
like, if, the one thing
that could have helped,
and this is all just
speculation,
if, if on,
if in these room sections,
if the select button was,
like, you could look at
your, uh,
your, uh, is it brother or uncle?
I don't remember. I think it's your brother.
Okay, just look at your brother's note,
and your brother's note
has some information,
and, like,
maybe it'll magically
reveal more
as you move forward.
I, I don't know.
I think that would have helped
both our complaints
in, uh, in,
in just how
labyrinthine this is,
and in this situation
as well. I think that would have been
great, Sean, actually,
because that adds to the,
you know,
um, the mystery element of it,
that you continue to kind of
uncover more of the mystery
of the house as you go along
via your brother's notes,
and that's something that
could have been done as the,
um, you know, after you defeat the boss
of a warp zone world,
you could have, like, collected a new note
from your brother that would have given you
context on where the next
warp zone was.
We've, we've improved the game,
Mike. Absolutely.
The one thing I will say
here, though, is that
even though it's hard
to figure out what to hit,
every other object
in this,
uh, in each of these rooms
is very clear
on what it is
and what to do, so there's no confusion
there. Um,
they, they've kept all the rooms
very plain, so you know
what a dresser is,
you know what a window is,
you know what a door is,
and that's really, like, even though it kind of
becomes tedious of just,
like, open up all these things,
very much so, but at your own risk.
At the same time, it is nice that they
didn't make a bunch of
objects that just don't
matter. Like, if you had to,
like, if they put a vase there
and you were like,
I gotta hit the vase
every time too,
or like,
you know, um,
you know,
there's a couch now
and you gotta check under
it, like, that stuff wouldn't,
that would just add even
more layers to it
that it doesn't necessarily
need. Yeah,
you're right. There are still items in
this that are sort of,
like, what's the point,
Dan? I mean, I know that,
like, it makes sense that a
cupboard will be empty.
I get that.
Uh, it makes sense that
a wardrobe will be empty.
It makes sense that a
window will have no
reason for you to climb through it.
But, there are doors that
you can open, and then when you
select to go through
the door, it says,
no way! And,
I don't know what
the difference is between
a no way door and a
door that your character
is okay walking
through. So,
I thought that was
weird. Um,
I don't know if that's just,
like, these doors are locked
until I collect
more things. You hit the nail on
the head there. That's exactly what it
is, and I think that sucks.
he just knows. He just knows that he
can't go through that.
Right, but again,
that's stupid. Like,
it doesn't help.
Don't make the door
locked and find a key
instead. Yeah,
yeah, exactly. I'm not,
it's not just gonna be
like, I'm too afraid at this
very moment, but I'll be brave
soon. I don't know.
Yeah, there's no,
like, Zelda temple in any
Zelda game where
it's just readily accessible and Link
doesn't walk in.
Instead, he just says, no way!
Like, that just doesn't
happen. Yeah.
All right, next point,
warp zone worlds,
I guess we're gonna call them.
This is after you
find, you know,
the window or door
that you need to walk through that
enters a warp zone,
and now it becomes
a little more of a
platformer than the
hallways ever were
because I'd say
it's more like a
action platformer
like, say, Castlevania was,
uh, and you have
to go,
you know, get, keep scrolling to
the end of the level,
and there's a boss fight there,
but in the meantime there's a bunch of
different enemies, the layout of the
terrain is different,
some are like underwater,
some are jungles,
some are rocky
sandcastle things,
uh, every warp zone is
different, and I think that's cool because it's an
interdimensional portal,
it should take you to
different locations.
What'd you think about this section?
Uh, I thought that they
were, uh,
you know, in terms of the
look and feel of the
game, they're kind of
breaths of fresh air,
you get a different color palette at the
very least, um,
there, it is more of a
traditional platformer
with, and it's not based off
of just, here's a flat
hallway, um,
that being said,
it really doesn't,
um, the mechanics of
the platforming
don't make this
feel good, like,
this sort of exposes that,
um, your jumps are
very stiff,
that your, uh,
attacks are
kind of
punchless,
um, it,
it's, uh, it doesn't make
the rest of the game feel that
much better, um,
I will say that,
uh, it is good that
you get to see
a cool new design
for a boss at the
end, um, because I do
think that these are also
well designed, um,
but in terms of
the gameplay itself,
it, it exposes its
weaknesses too much.
Yeah, and I think,
you know, there's also a,
uh, a platformer problem
in a lot of
these, uh, these zones,
because the jump
on the character
isn't that great,
and the,
the, the common idea
in the game design
here is just like,
oh, if you fall off
the, like, path we had
designed, you fall to the
bottom of the screen, and now you
have to walk yourself back
and re-try to
climb all this stuff.
Yeah, exactly.
And so that's not fun either,
because that's just a,
another repetitive decision there,
uh, and the bosses
are, are strange.
They're, they're not
exactly the
hard boss fights
I'm used to, they were
manageable, but at the
same time, they're not
necessarily, at least in
the early ones, they're not
necessarily enemies
that read any
different than the enemies that
you've been seeing the whole time.
Well, I mean, they,
they read differently than
just the trash
mobs that,
Oh no, I'm sorry, yeah,
they are definitely,
uh, like, designed unique.
Uh, what I mean is,
is that they're
not necessarily, like,
harder or to,
to a, to a bigger scale,
or like a, you know,
there's no feeling of,
like, this is a boss
battle until,
I guess, like, later on in the
game, as I'm starting to look at some of
these enemy, bosses I didn't
fight. But the,
the first, like,
the first two bosses that I
remember, one was like a,
a squirrel looking
thing, and the other one
was a ghost? Yeah,
I mean, that,
I, I get that.
I mean, I didn't think that they were
much harder than,
I, I just had trouble
with this game because it was so
stiff, so,
um, I,
I was using my gun, and that,
you know, I,
I may have
been a little
lax with my
ammunition prior
to that, but,
um, I'm not gonna
say that I
won the first
time I ran
into one of these things.
Got it. But,
you're right, the,
the boss, in terms of
mechanically,
the boss designs are,
are not very
good. I,
I was just impressed by
their, uh, visual design.
Yeah, and I think,
you know, the only,
uh, saving grace
there with the, with the gun,
and, um, I think you
also have, like, an Uzi,
and a, and a bunch
of grenades. The,
the thing there
is, you can collect
a lot of that stuff.
Like, you could have 65 bullets,
you could have 99 bullets,
like, it's all up to
how much you explore the
house beforehand
going into these levels.
Like, so, it does, it does make
sense to explore all the
rooms rather than just
jump right into the warp zones
because you might come unprepared.
Yeah, and that is
sort of a thing that,
like, it does seem
proto-survival
horror-y, um,
and with the,
with the kind
of, um, resource management
that you have to do, it's not balanced
well, you usually get
more than you need,
I was just
very bad at the game,
um, but I,
I can kind of see a
glimmer of
survival horror in that design.
Yeah, and so,
you know, you face off
against these bosses,
you go through, um,
these levels, you usually get
a piece of
your laser, um,
like a piece of your laser gun,
you need 11 pieces
to get the laser gun
to help you defeat
the last boss in
the game, and then you
also collect at the same time
a item that is
only good for
like, you know,
to help you get through like
another section. So the first one
gives you like the ultra space
sensor, uh,
you can get an air helmet,
you can get jump shoes that
let you, uh, jump a lot higher,
um, there's a bunch
of things like that and those
are cool because
they help you
power up, but they,
they aren't like substantial or,
or changing
power ups in the
sense of, you know,
things that you got in Metroid.
Yeah, they don't, they don't change
the way you really play the
game that,
and some of them just act as
keys and I hate
that when it comes to upgrades.
Exactly, yeah,
like the air helmet is only
designed so that you can finally
go to the underwater warp
zones because if you get there
too early, you won't be able
to explore those
underwater warp zones.
Yeah, but again,
this wasn't really a game
that I was expecting,
like an upgrade path,
so it didn't,
it wasn't as
big of a con
to me as it
would have been in, say,
a shmup, but it's still
like, they didn't do
it right. Yeah,
and it's an interesting decision
to get like two
power-up collectibles
at once, like you get the
laser gun, which is like your
key to beating the final boss,
and then you also get this like
smaller thing that
just kind of helps you as a
character progress to whatever would
be the next warp
zone. Yeah,
it's a little redundant.
Yeah, well, the redundant
part comes next
because you see after you defeat
the boss and collect those
things, you don't get
like warped
back to the
room that you were in or
even to the hallway part
where you were. You have to
just walk
back, take the
trek, yeah,
back through the whole
warp zone again and
climb back out
the door or window of which
you came from. I don't know,
I guess it does
kind of make sense,
like why would you be warped
out of it? You weren't
warped into it,
I suppose, but it just felt
like unnecessary backtracking and
I didn't enjoy it.
Yeah, I think in a game
that you've already established that
warp zones are a
thing, you could have
like explained it
away that way.
This is the game
to warp back.
Right, right, yeah,
exactly. The warp zones
in the title and
then you're not doing anything
that's funny. Yeah.
So Sean, as you mentioned,
11 warp zones
in all and at
the end of the
first 10, warp zones,
you gotta fight
a boss,
then you get the laser piece
and then you finally take down
the final boss.
Just think about
how long it took you and I don't
know how far you got, I really only
got up to
probably warp
zone 4. Think about how
long that took
and now,
is this really
how long you
want this game to be?
Like, was 11 too
much at a certain point?
Again, my opinion may
have changed if I was
around when this game
came out. It has the
password, so it's not
like you have to do it all
in one playthrough.
And I would
want more
content on my
game, so maybe
then I would
say, like, no, this is just
the perfect length. But no,
you're right, at this very
moment in time,
it's kind of long.
Yeah, and you know,
it's funny because we didn't talk
about the password system
at all, but this might
be the first
game where
you can just
choose to
discontinue at any time and
get the password
prompt and then
shut down the game.
Like, you don't have
to wait till
you beat the next boss to
get the password.
Oh, that's what,
I thought it was a typo.
Like, why would you want to
discontinue? Oh,
yeah, you're talking about in the
manual? Yeah.
Yeah, it's really
funny because it gives you
a very detailed
explanation on
how to even like begin
a game.
Yeah. Like, push start,
choose new game. But yeah,
to discontinue is a weird
phrase of
words. That's probably why I said
it because I was glossing
over the manual before we started.
But I do think that's
interesting that
like there's a way to
get the password to
appear on screen because
there's a lot of times where,
you know, you're a kid and your mom
says you got to go somewhere and
they don't understand that
you can't
save. Yeah.
So, everybody's been
there. So, I think it's a
nice touch that
they put that in there.
Yeah, I guess I
didn't even notice that
that was one
of those quality of life
things in there. But that's
cool. You're right.
A longer game,
especially on
an NES or something like
that, is helpful
when they
include either a save or
a password system.
and, you know,
I probably
shouldn't have said,
like, is it bad that the
game's so long? I guess what
I really meant is that
you're doing
the same explore the
room, find the
warp zone, get through
the warp zone, defeat the
boss, like, you're doing
the same thing over
and over again.
And I guess at a
certain point you could say
a game like
Legend of Zelda
also is that,
right? Like, you go and
find a dungeon. That's kind of what games are.
It's called a gameplay loop.
Yeah. Yeah, you know,
but I think that this
gameplay loop is too
redundant because the
power-ups you get don't
substantially change the
game in
any way that makes it,
like, more fun.
You know, we were saying Metroid earlier.
Like, it feels good,
Mega Man even,
it feels good
to have,
even if the
stage idea is the same of
exploring the stages, it feels good
to have new power-ups that
you get to, like, fully take
advantage of, and this game
doesn't have a
moment like that. Yeah,
I guess what I
mean is that
it's not, yeah,
it's not the
game's fault that
it's giving you
more content, it's just that
there isn't very,
so there's not a
lot of, there's not any
escalation of
difficulty, well,
maybe there's an escalation of
difficulty, but it's the
same low level
of fun throughout.
Like, it's neat,
but I wouldn't
really say that,
like, you get into a
situation where, like, oh,
I can do this now,
so I'm going to have fun
with this mechanic now.
Like, it's just the same thing
the whole time.
So yeah, you're right. And not to be
surprised, no sequels and
spinoffs for Dr.
Chaos. not even like
a little, like,
15 minute TV show,
like, you usually have
15 things.
I know, I was thinking
about, like, where's the
Game Boy game? Yeah.
But this game
was published by FCI,
the same people that brought us
Mag Max, so,
and C-Cross,
I-Cross, whatever you want
to call it, they brought us
those games, so it seems like
they kind of just bring these games
on and then forget about them
because neither of those games
got sequels either.
They probably are only interested
in what we like
to call original titles.
They're always
daring, always innovative.
Very daring. Yep.
And the developer,
I think their name was Marionette,
I couldn't even find anything else
about this company.
Marionette. This might have
been the only game they made,
and it's
interesting because the producer
for Dr. Chaos would
go on to make a ton of
early RPGs
like Bard's Tale,
Ultima 6,
Pool of Radiance,
as a producer,
not as a writer or
developer or anything.
But I think that's pretty neat
that he started
at Dr. Chaos and went
on to work on these big
RPGs. But then
the designer,
Saishi Yokata,
never again
was he heard from.
He designed
this game, and they were
like, goodbye.
It was his swan song.
Yeah, hand in your
keys to your
video game developer because
you're not allowed to,
you're not allowed to talk
anymore. You're not
allowed to talk anymore.
That's what they say to you.
That's like the goodbye kiss.
Once you're told
you're not allowed to talk anymore,
you may as well
just pack up your box.
All right, we're going to
give Dr. Chaos our
goodbye kiss
in the
Essential Games
list. Okay,
it's time for the Essential
Games list. Sorry if that
sounded like we weren't going to
vote Dr. Chaos into the
Essential Games list. We're definitely
going to give it a fair trial,
and that trial
starts with Sean.
All right, well, I'll be its
judge, jury, and executioner
right now. The game,
I like this
style. I still think
it has potential,
like this whole
side-scroller
slash
genre that we
keep running into,
but it's
still, the execution
is not there
in terms of
keeping the game fun,
and having
actual kind of
discovery happening
when you're in
this first-person
mode. It's just going through
the motions. I did really
like the design
of a lot of the enemies,
at least for the ones that
would come in and chase you,
because that was spooky,
but all
told, the game
is mediocre
at best,
so it is not
going on my
essential games
list. All right,
and that means it can't be on
the essential games list,
because both of us would have
to vote it on. True.
But I really
forgot for a
minute how scary the idea
of monsters
coming through
open doors,
like doors that you already
thought were safe,
is. And for
that, this game
is a true
innovation. Like,
in many ways,
there's nothing scarier yet
on the NES
than this
moment, where open
doors can reveal gigantic
monsters that
will be sure to kill you.
Aside from
NES baseball.
Right, right, in which case
all the players are ghosts.
But, you know,
to get back on topic here,
the game is
ultimately just like a series
of confusing
design decisions,
specifically around the
first person
mode and
the warp zone
world. So,
that really just means
the whole game's fun
is contained to exploring
the hallways, and I
wouldn't say that.
No. So, this is what,
the design
aspect of this
game is really what puts this
off my essential games
list. I'm totally
willing to welcome longer
games onto the NES,
but not when
long also means
tedious. And so,
I'm not surprised that
the designer of this game
didn't get much work afterwards,
and I'm also not surprised to
see it removed
or never on
our essential games list.
Very harsh. Well,
you were the executioner.
I just came
in and hit a home run.
I, like, I, we were trying,
I guess we were playing, like,
good executioner,
bad executioner there.
I hate when we do that,
but it's true. Yeah.
What, you know, since no one
else is around, what other
NES hot takes
do you want to just, like,
give out right now? You know,
I was, I was never
really a fan
of, like,
how you put in a cartridge.
I thought it should always be,
like, it's a Nintendo
game, like,
you should be able to see,
like, the, the box art.
Oh, so you're saying
you're a fan of the top
loader design and not the
original NES. I'm not saying
I'm a fan of the top loader
design. I think it could have been
done better. I think that,
like, you know, if the cartridge
was designed better,
like, it would, it would be,
it would look more, it would look
more natural like the
Super NES. Okay,
okay, I, I could see
that. My hot take,
Super Mario Brothers 2
better than Super Mario
Brothers 1. Wow.
100% the truth.
Did you, did you say
that in the episode? You know,
I don't know, but I do know
that I said in the episode
that Nintendo
Power said
it's the best of the three.
Ooh, so.
And that's crazy. That's like,
that's like a
parent picking
a favorite, you know?
Yeah. You know,
speaking of Nintendo Power,
we do have
to cover
the next issue
of Nintendo Power
in one of our
post shows. So I think,
you know, we have a great
episode next week,
Super Mario Brothers slash
Duck Hunt. I think it's a game
where Mario slashes the
Duck Hunt dog after it laughed
at you so many times.
Oof. Or maybe
it's, um, maybe it's
like a gumshoe-esque
game where
you, uh,
control a zapper for
Super Mario and every time
you shoot, he jumps
instead. And,
uh, you just, you manually
control the
reticle in, uh,
this, this Duck Hunt
platformer. Yep.
Okay. Wow. I think this
sounds great. Yeah.
Uh, that's a great
episode that we have for you next
time. We're definitely going to make it
interesting and unique.
It won't just be
coverage of Super Mario
Brothers and Duck Hunt,
so stick around for that.
And also,
you know, another game coming
up, Super Team Games.
I, I'm not sure,
uh, if that is,
quite makes sense.
Like, if you had to guess,
Super Team Games,
what are you thinking? Um,
I'm, well, I'm not thinking any
sport. Maybe it's going to be
like, like dodgeball and a
bunch of other weird things.
I don't know. I went to dodgeball
too. I went to dodgeball,
kickball, tug of war.
Yeah, yeah, they're just gym
games, gym class games.
Foursquare. Oh,
I love the Foursquare.
That's not a team game,
though. Yeah,
it's really not. You're right.
We should figure out a way to make
Foursquare a team game.
We could do it. But that,
that's a great episode coming up,
so maybe we'll also do Nintendo Power
number three in that,
uh, in that issue.
Let's do it. Sorry,
I should have mentioned, NostalgiaCast is
becoming a magazine. We're going to have,
uh, monthly issues.
Yeah, monthly issues of
NostalgiaCast. Uh,
they'll all be typed up by Sean.
On my, uh,
on my typewriter.
Yes. We just sent out
the manuscripts. Yep.
It's, um, it's going to be a
thing. We just need it
funded. So, if you want it
funded, type in
fundies
on Twitter and send it to
at NostalgiaCast
and that's your
way of donating
to the fundamentals
of funding
the magazine.
I, I won't be a part
of this. I'm not on the
Twitter, but, I'm looking forward
to hearing about it.
You know, NostalgiaCast is on
the Twitter at NostalgiaCast.
I'm on the Twitter at Esposito Film.
He is
Sean. I am.
Insert last name.
And, this has been
a great episode
of Nostalgia.
Sean, take it away.
And I
will always
love you.
00 00
00 00 00
00 Thank you.